marcela lorenzo vive en este pequeño
apartamento con dos de sus hijos y su
pareja aquí le encontró la pandemia
intentando combinar las tareas del hogar
su actividad en la comunidad
afroargentina y sus estudios para
docentes de primaria los más duros
fueron los primeros meses del encierro
ay fueron caóticos caóticos porque llegó
un momento te digo julio vacaciones de
julio que en realidad no fueron
vacaciones pero así como colapsada la
situación de marcela se repitió millones
de hogares en todo el país con una
sobrecarga de tareas domésticas tal como
determinó un estudio que llevó adelante
la investigadora karina vida seca
expresó en forma significativa en que el
92 por ciento más exactamente un 92,6 se
encargaron de acompañar las actividades
escolares de los hijos y hess la
sobrecarga terminó teniendo un efecto
emocional
la psicóloga sandra berna voz ha estado
siguiendo a muchas mujeres a lo largo de
la pandemia lo que se siente es
el estrés por un lado el hartazgo el
agotamiento en muchos momentos la
sensación de desesperanza
yo veo estragos importantes ya los veo
este veo niveles de irritabilidad muy
grandes veo vínculos que se han
deteriorado un montón en su casa a
marcela lorenzo pasó por algunas de esas
emociones creo que en un momento colapse
con la as-ii con la casa con la sede con
la familia con la obsecuencia estudios
novia es esa interacción ese encuentro
con el otro con la otra con el otro lo
necesito muchísimo viste es como de
encontrarme levantarme y que hago pero
el desafío ahora a medida que se abre
más y más actividades es desarmar la
rutina del encierro por lo pronto ella
está dando más espacio a sus estudios su
activismo social y saliendo algunos días
por semana a trabajar acercándose de a
poco a algo parecido a la normalidad